oh
i saw more of those freaky murals
did they start making sense tell any
sort of story
all just a bunch of tarot cards
i'm pretty sure my brain's now beyond
repair
the tarot tells the story of a fool's
journey
show me what you found i'll tell you
what's left
here you're still missing two arcana
judgment and the devil my guess is that
they relate to a turning point in your
life
one that's soon to arrive
what's this judgment about one possible
future
of redemption transition awakening
the angel with the trumpet symbolizes
the end of an era
and the call to rebirth to a new
beginning
rather not run into the devil got a
feeling he's bad vibes
that's the card of primal dormant
desires but also the will to survive
hmm doesn't sound so bad actually it
also represents a false world
the trap these desires lay for you
what's up with the wandering fool the
fool is you and silverhand
you've traveled a long road together
discovered your potential
and where we headed your destination is
the world
the final arcanum both of you waged a
war on the world
so there are two possibilities declare
victory
or make peace could lose the war too
yes unfortunately that's true
thanks didn't get much of that but
thanks you'll understand when the time
comes
i can't explain everything all the tarot
can tell me is that you will reach the
world by one of four paths
meaning the final leg of the journey
goes through the sun
the star temperance or the devil
could just die not even get that far
oh come on you won't let that happen
take this that's all i can do to help
good luck v on whatever road you choose
is
you